Fourteen years after Disney Pixar released
their 2004 animated film, The Incredibles
they will be releasing a sequel about the
family with superpowers.
The plot is kept under wraps and there is
much speculation as to what the plot will
be.
With speculation comes theories and there
is one theory that focuses on the petite fashion
designer, Edna Mode’s past.
The popular theory suggests that Edna is a
reformed supervillain and the reasons this
theory is in speculation are not only fun
but intriguing.
Remember to subscribe to Screen Rant and comment
below with your views on this theory.
Here is Screen Rant’s look into an 'Incredibles'
Theory That Pixar Might Be Hiding From Us.
Villainous Facility
Her home or dare we say liar looked oddly
similar to a villain’s home in a James Bond
film.
Her entrance gate has lasers instead of bars
and when her security system thought Elastigirl
was not invited they almost took her out.
Then when she showed Elastigirl her design
for Jack-Jack’s outfit she tested the durability
with flamethrowers and automatic weapons.
Now, we know many of you would love to have
those installed in your house but you have
to admit it’s from your villainous side.
Love for Danger
In scenes of The Incredibles Edna showed a
love for danger and she missed seeing her
superhero clients working.
When they were working there was a sense of
danger and she enjoyed every minute of it.
She longed for the old days but more importantly
she wasn’t afraid to get feisty with superheroes.
She didn’t back down from them and pushed
them to do her will.
These are characters that could crush her
in a moment and that is probably why she confronted
them.
Contempt for Her Guards
Her guards seemed to get on her nerves, almost
as if she didn’t want them to be there.
Are her guards put there by the government
to ensure she doesn’t come up with any new
technological advances that could hurt the
country?
What if they are put there to guard her like
the superheroes are being looked over.
Why are these guards living with her and no
one else and why would a simple designer even
need guards?
Think about the Emperor’s Guards in Star
Wars, do you ever see Luke Skywalker with
a guard or how about his costume designer?
What have you been up to Edna?
Jack-Jack’s Outfit
Edna designed an outfit for Jack-Jack with
all of the bells and whistles claiming that
she gave him all of those retardants because
she didn’t know his powers yet.
How did she know he would need to be able
to withstand 1000 degrees of heat?
She seemed very certain that he had superhero
powers when his mother, who raised him, didn’t
even know he had them.
Luckily she did see into the future because
Jack-Jack did have a use for that new outfit.
A Villain’s Mind
Even if Edna didn’t know Jack-Jack would
have superpowers she prepared an outfit for
him to be protected when Syndrome goes after
him.
She knew how a villain thought and was one
step ahead of him.
Villains are prone to disliking boredom and
so is Edna, she wanted the thrill again and
mentioned her need for a thrill many times.
Remember she used to design for Gods and supermodels
bore her.
Dressed to Kill
Edna was dressed like a villain, look at her
outfit and compare it to villains in other
Disney films.
Lined up next to Cruella de Vil or Maleficent
you can see where she could get her inspiration
from them.
Maybe she designed her clothes after watching
a Disney movie or after a meeting with fellow
Disney villains.
That would be an interesting meeting to be
a part of.
What do you think about the theory on Edna?
Is Edna Mode a former villain turned good
guy who started to design superhero outfits
to atone for her evil ways?
If she is a reformed supervillain we hope
those glasses have special powers and we get
to see them in the sequel.
There you have it an 'Incredibles' Theory
That Pixar Might Be Hiding From Us.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos like this one.
Thanks for watching.